[Musique]
sa fin j'aurais dû le faire
j'ai traîné c'est une erreur maintenant
on va corriger le tir on va changer un
peu les choses je fais donc équipé le
studio enfin d'une alarme il était torse
et êtes vous venu partenaires les
marques qu'elle est un petit peu
rassurant les en quoi avec tout le matos
gros à ce n'est qu il na pas d alarme
s'assurer vous rassure vous je m'équipe
enfin je m'équipe jeune équipe charnacé
devise s vise église qui m'envoyait du
matériel donc ici on a une caméra à 360
degrés de s ville on va regarder ça dans
quelques instants
on a également une sirène parce qu'une
alarme ces liens mais pour que ce
dissuasif faut que ça fasse beaucoup de
bruit ça c'est cool également on a
ensuite un capteur de présence
forcément paf pour vous captez dès que
vous arrivez vous unit la valeur est en
fuite
on a un détecteur d'ouverture de portes
et fenêtres
comment souvent sympa la petite caméra
360 donc avec motorisés elle pilote
permet de voir tous les côtés de le
mettre en ethernet et une carte micro sd
qu'on peut mettre à l'intérieur petite
documentation pour comprendre comment ça
marche
qu'est ce qu'on a c'est quoi ça voyez ce
métier de contact ok bon on va regarder
ça plus en détails parce que là pour
l'instant je suis vraiment en train de
découvrir assez un contact gic ans un
contact de portes et fenêtres
lyès ça c'est vachement bien ok cool
j'ai de quoi les coller
en dessous on va avoir une alimentation
en observe détecteur présence pareil on
a un petit manuel d'utilisation et enfin
c'est pour le coller ok on a ensuite ici
la sirène mais enfin on a un détecteur
ici laissez molleton branché de
configurer tout ça et vous en parle très
rapidement pour moi ça va durer le temps
que ça durera pour vous sera le temps
d'un claquement de doigts
quelques mois quand j'ai vu arriver des
quantités astronomiques de matériel que
je testais ce qui est toujours le cas
aujourd'hui
j'ai commencé un petit peu subi un bon
voilà je suis quand même dans mon studio
il ya pas d alarme ça va être un peu
compliqué du coup j'ai discuté avec
elvis qui m'a équipé en matériel et qui
m'envoyait du matos à c'était l'année
dernière il ya quelques mois j'ai traîné
énormément j'ai commencé à tourner le 12
novembre cette vidéo là tout de suite on
est le combien on est on est on est le
carnet et joue ça fait très longtemps va
donc désolé visa ventre et dès
aujourd'hui tout est là tout installer
donc ça fait déjà quelques mois que je
teste le matériel dans le studio
suffisait juste de prendre les caméras
de tourner comme ça c'était donc ça
c'est fait aujourd'hui donc je démontre
un peu mon installation
je vous explique comment ça marche je
voulais être soudain vraiment
intéressant et je vous explique aussi le
poids un peu négatif il ya forcément des
trucs positifs des trucs qui vont un peu
moins bien
et au final je vous dis ceci satisfait
oui ou non première chose je vous montre
un peu la configuration pour voyez
comment ça marche
le premier truc qui est ici dans le
décor je sais pas si vous avez fait
gaffe c'est ça la ces petites caméras à
360 degrés qui est installé depuis de
longs mois et qui est complètement
motorisée de dire qu'elle va pouvoir
tourner à 360 degrés monté en haut
descendre en bas pas seulement et du
coup elle va repérer d'où vient le
mouvement et elle va le prendre
elle va finir vous avez deux solutions
soit vous le film est directement sur
une carte microsd que vous êtes à
l'intérieur ce qui pourront par contre
assez peu d'intérêt parce qu'au final le
personne qui vient vous cambrioler la
cave embarqué ça ou prendre la carte et
puis vous avez aucune image sans vous
faites comme moi vous êtes connecté
directement dans le club par un petit
abonnement et au final vous avez accès
aux données tout le temps donc la
personne que vous voulez tout votre
matos vous avez en tout cas les images
via ses plus importants le deuxième il
est là en hausse à l'effet que leur
mouvement bon comme son nom l indique
dès qu'un mouvement dans la pièce paf
il le reconnaît le troisième c'est sur
une ouverture ouvertures de fenêtres
quand la fed va s'ouvrir
il les reconnaît ensuite vous arrivez
ici sur la porte du studio dès que la
porte s'ouvre
le capteur de plus en face ça déclenche
alarme et enfin elle a l'art en elle
même qui est planqué dans un van du
studio croyait boissel la côte elle
sonne ça vous réveille du monde le
principe est le suivant
là je suis dans le studio suis dans le
mode à domicile c'est à dire que tout
est désactivé
la caméra filme en permanence mais par
contre tous les capteurs sont désactivés
maintenant j'ai passé en mode hors
domicile c'est à dire que tous les
capteurs vont s'activer
vous allez voir ça va pas tarder à
couiner voilà donc là ça cuit et moi
j'ai une explication sans doute
hellickson qu'english et quelques uns la
maison bon voilà le principe en gros
quel que soit le moyen par lequel vous
allez rentrer dans le studio et bien ça
va sonner le pointer un peu plus limité
c'est que c'est à vous d'appeler la
police
le point qui est positif c'est quand
même là l'arbre est lé queens énormément
et si vous avez des voisins croyez moi
ça va les réveiller croyez moi ça va
c'est vraiment dissuasive maintenant que
je vais un peu regretter c'est au niveau
sept caméras
c'est cette caméra là alors je trouve
autant très pratique parce qu'elle est
complètement motorisés moi qui se passe
à elle valait dessus elle va directement
film et ça c'est cool
elle est totalement active et donc même
quand on est à distance vous pouvez
regarder ce qui se passe pas un instant
t bon c'est bien pour pouvoir surveiller
regard des bons recrutements étant le
seul truc c'est que dès qu'elle va
capter l une modification de pixels elle
va considérer que c'est du mouvement et
elle se met à sonner
le problème c'est que si vous avez comme
moi une fenêtre et vous avez sol et qui
arrive la journée qui paraît bien vous
allez avoir des changements pixels haut
niveau la lumière elle va où elle peut
en tout cas l'assimiler à un mouvement
vous pouvez avoir un faux positif une
alarme 10 mai a sonné alors qu'ils se
passe absolument rien alors vous le
voyez sur votre notification vous
regardez vous et qui absolument rien
vous comprenez c'est ça vous désactivez
vous réactivez ça c'est pas tout le
temps mais quand elle fait des fois vous
faites un peu des fausses frayeurs de la
côte et il vaut mieux qu'elle fasse son
job un peu plus qu'un peu moins mais
quand vous savez ça va alerter le
voisinage
ça peut aussi être le point un petit peu
négatif il existe donc une application
qui ici c'est l'application est ce vous
avez retrouvé votre caméra vous allez
pouvoir paramétrer vos modes mode à
domicile donc la caméra d'activer une
mode en domicile quand vous partez mode
sommeil
la grosse différence que vous allez
avoir entre les deux c'est les
périphériques que vous allez pouvoir
activer désactiver
vous avez bien évidemment le dr capter
voyant d'état lampe infrarouge votre
caméra elle marche dans la nuit ce peut
être un toutes les lumières vous verrez
comme en plein jour ça c'est vraiment
vraiment intéressant notification
d'ahlam sensibilité mouvements sont
notifications envoyées et pas mal de
deux petits paramètres et bientôt qui
est vachement bien qui est tout nouveau
c'est l'armement de la programmation
vous pouvez l'armée
les joueurs gardois par exemple chez moi
à 19h valable tous les jours paf elle ce
nom vous pouvez très bien de chez vous
par exemple l'alarmé est en mode sommeil
de 23h jusqu'à 7 heures du matin et que
entre milliers de vous n'aimez pas la
larme qui est taxi vous pouvez tout
paramétrer ici ça c'est vachement
intéressant vous avez ici toutes vos
images avec tout ce qui a été enregistré
et là pouvaient venir ensuite régler
votre compte si ça faisait pas mal de
petites possibilités vous avez cette
télécommande qu'elle y le kit principale
posée pouvoir faire la même chose que
vous faites dans votre application mais
avec des boutons le mode je suis à la
maison je pars la maison le mode nuit
alarme complètement désactivé ici et là
vous faites sonner c'est relativement
pratique vous pouvez attacher à votre
porte clés quand vous arrivez vous
activer ou désactiver
bon c'est assez simple on est sur une
saison je trouve assez intéressante
alors vous pouvez l'acheter en cliquant
vous avez tout d'abord salah avec la
caméra principale la télécommande et le
capteur de porte
ça vous allez trouver au tarif de 100
euros voir un petit peu moins cher si
vous intéresse d'ailleurs choqué ni trop
lentement que boulanger je vous ai mis
un lien dans la description vous allez
ensuite où trouver au même prix la
sirène la 50 euros le détecteur
d'ouverture fermeture t6 pareil 50 euros
et le capteur de mouvement pareil 50
euros en gros pour 250 euros vous avez
un kit complet qui vous permet de
sécuriser votre intérieur alors je dis
ce kit complet oui et non parce qu'il
faut quand même penser une petite carte
microsd si toutefois vous voulez
utiliser une carte microsd bon je vous
conseille quand même de prendre un
abonnement dans le club et moi ça doit
coûter 49 euros 99 pour avoir un
abonnement de 1 an dans le club pour
stocker toutes les vidéos qu'ils sont
filmés
et croyez-moi ça quand même plutôt bien
et plutôt sécurisant
ce que je trouve bien c'est que vous
avez effectivement du matos si vous avez
votre solution
votre kit complet pour dire sécurisé
alors appelé à défendre votre intérieur
parce que moi j'ai un studio qui paraît
énorme mais si vous avez beaucoup de
fenêtres et voulait mettre un capteur
par fenêtre elle vous rajoutez un peu
d'argent à chaque fois à mon avis la clé
de ce genre de configuration s'est
positionné vos capteurs au bon endroit
si vous en mettez assure chaque porte et
chaque fenêtre bout d'un moment ça a
coûté quand même relativement cher si
par exemple vous installer ça à un
endroit stratégique
vous allez couvrir une bonne partie de
votre pièce idem avec la caméra donc bon
vous sécuriser les zones de passage et
ça vraiment venir couvrir les zones
principales il faut de plus ces produits
vous intéresse vous a mis un lien en bas
d'un discret topic
aide-moi vous ce que vous en pensez est
ce que vous avez besoin d'une à la messe
que vous utilisez une alarme et est ce
que vous trouvez ça intéressant moi
j'aime ça coûte parce que vous
réussissez quand même à allier alarme
objet connecté avec votre smartphone
tout connecté votre carrière enfin
parler canada par un côté un peu plus
sécurisant vous invite à me dire que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire et
à vous abonner comme ça vous saurez tout
pour suivre toute l'actualité tech vous
donne rendez vous dès demain vous
embrasse